alright guys you know I don't talk about
a lot of movie news on my channel unless
it's something that really interests me
the joke is my boys are this really
interesting because it's crazy to a
convoluted degree and I have a lot of
thoughts about what's going down
basically the news broke that there is
going to be a new Joker movie that's a
standalone Joker movie it's going to
have a new actor to play the Joker
that's not really linked to the decent
you you it looks to be an origin story
right out the game I'm gonna get on this
[ __ ] I am interested in a standalone
Joker movie I'd love to see a movie that
concentrates on my boy I don't want an
origin story you tell us origins it puts
him in a box it limits it that's how I
feel anyway and if you're gonna
reference The Killing Joke in the
comment section it's my least favorite
thing about The Killing Joke
he's crazy because he feels justified in
being crazy maybe he's not as nuts as we
think maybe he's just the realist in
which case we're all sane because we
have blinders to the real world it's the
only way you can be said that's why I
love the Joker it's like Billy Loomis
and screams said did Norman Bates have a
motive do they ever find out why
Hannibal Lecter like to eat people see
it's scarier when there's no motive of
course Norman Bates and Hannibal Lecter
now have an origin story no [ __ ] there
goes that and the crazy thing yeah this
is a crazy thing this is just one of the
planned many in fact it's one of a
series of movies that isn't linked to
the DC EU but we'll have the DC
characters which is worried they're
gonna clarify that in the coming days or
is just gonna stand is exactly what it
sounds like which is yes is going to be
the DC EU and the standalone DC movies
that have characters from the DC EU but
different actors portraying them in the
stand-alones as opposed to the DC EU
that's me Sam we're gonna have to
Aquaman I guess or Aquaman's weird is
Martin Scorsese's gonna produce this
movie I get the potential for quality
here but it all depends on how involved
in producing Scorsese's gonna be example
Steven Spielberg produced the first
Transformers movie I don't know how
involved he was on that thing and if he
was really involved trust me people in
the comment section are gonna let me
know point is when I watched the first
Transformers movie it doesn't feel like
a Steven Spielberg movie to me so I
personally am NOT going to expect this
Joker movie to feel like a Martin
Scorsese film the word we're getting is
this joker the story he's in is gonna be
an eighties crime story so an eighties
crime story that concentrates on the
Joker and shows his origin that's a
standalone not part of a cinematic
universe are they just re releasing the
Burton Batman in theatres twitter loves
I guess Todd Phillips is one of the
writers on this project he directed the
hangover trilogy and war dogs I don't
know what that speaks Joker movie to me
I feel like todd phillips being one of
the writers is going to have more to do
with what the end product
this movie is and Martin Scorsese as a
producer I'd like him to come out and be
like hey douchebag on YouTube this is
exactly how involved I'm going to be I
feel bad for Jared I'll lose the fans
hated his guts as a jumper and I feel
bad for the dear dad all this pressure
to live up to the Heath Ledger Joker so
his Joker ultimately was some form of an
impersonation of Heath Ledger's Joker
doing full method he mailed rats and
condoms to people who's like how crazy
the Joker is and in the end you really
didn't need to be in the movie and now
it looks like that story that Jared Leto
was promised is going to happen with
someone else point is I feel like Jared
Leto has promised one thing and got
another but origin aside a standalone
movie would work because there have been
some quality standalone Joker stories
out there take Brian Azzarello as Joker
Batman was in the very end of that story
in the end it seemed through the eyes of
his driver who really is like I kind of
get the Joker I totally get this guy
we're becoming close he gets me he's
gonna learn a rough lesson that in the
end the Joker doesn't give a [ __ ] about
you Joker cares about the Joker he's a
sadistic bastard
and in the end I want them to learn from
their mistakes on this don't overcook
the Joker
whatever actor takes us on don't feel
pressure to live up to Heath Ledger's
joke make the Joker yours make him a
presence a powerful presence in any room
in the eye just think of it this way
The Joker's a monster what makes
monsters laugh monstrous things he
should feel scary not crazy his
eccentric nature is the byproduct of his
core make his core the showcase and he
house my thoughts this news interest me
my question is is the DC EU still going
to happen or are they gearing a series
of self-contained DC movies up while
they're winding the DC EU down or
they're gonna happen simultaneously if
they happen side by side the DC EU is
happening while this series of
standalone DC character films was
happening this very comic book multiple
takes on the same characters unrelated
unlinks different universes which trade
differently with different tone
nothing's more comic-book down fruit
Joker standalone movie don't want to see
his origin but if you're gonna show me
his origin I hope it's [ __ ] amazing
alright guys so with Joker standalone
movie what do you think about that which
actor would you like to play the Joker
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]